In a world where scammers run a muck,
one internet detective is ready to call all of them out.
Ladies and gentlemen, without further ado,
I am your CFO coffees. Hello, and welcome to fake guru Fridays guys.
That's right. That's each day has a theme and we're bringing it back.
Fake GRU Fridays is one of my favorite days that I don't know,
we just kind of lost it in the mix. So we're bringing it back.
And today we're answering an age old question, which is, you know,
pyramid schemes are often pitched to people who don't have much financial
know-how.
They're usually pitched to lower income communities who just don't know better.
Who are desperate. You know, you get the idea. It's nothing on them.
It's just this predatory tactic.
But what happens when you try to pitch to real investors,
a pyramid scape, you know, an insane idea. What do you do?
What a real investors do when they are pitched insane ideas? Well,
the result is incredible. Uh, but for this,
we're going to have to go to the computer. So let's go, wow, look,
nice graphics, fancy graphics paid a lot of money for that.
I hope you guys appreciate the $10 million studio guys. Let's be real,
uh, very legitimate. So see, I look, some people say it's a green screen.
Can't be a green screen. I'm wearing green right now.
So that's a possible anyways, let's get this started.
Shall we okay. Up? Not the right page.
We'll edit that out. Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a man trying to hide behind a white presentation and he's about to get
destroyed. Let me set this up. Let me set the stage. So this is Dragon's den.
It's like shark tank. If you know it from the U S basically people come on,
they pitch their investment ideas to actual investors who have run real
businesses.
I'm not saying those investors are perfect because we've talked about some of
their shady business dealings, but in this case, justice is about to be served,
not to be served real nice.
Hello dragons. My name is Andy [inaudible] and I'm from Brampton, Ontario.
I stand humbly before you today to offer you a historical business
opportunity.
Already off to a bad start. Why the big breath? Okay.
Orange money. You're looking for any, I'm looking for
175,000 of your hard earned dollars, which works out to $35,000 per dragon.
As I would like all five of you on board. What do we get?
How much of the company, uh, if you could please let me finish my pitch. Uh,
I will lead up to it. I have important information.
It's not a product that I'm selling. Okay, go ahead. Thank you very much. Ma'am.
This guy, the balls on this guy already. How do you go?
They're investing in you. You don't go. Hey, sir. Please shut up.
I'll take questions at the end of this presentation.
Oh, nice. Arlene. I would like all five of you on board in exchange,
you will get a business package within our rapidly growing company.
Does business package will be responsible in the near future for bringing you
huge returns.
That's the face that I'm giving right now. Buzzword buzzword,
buzzword business package.
Buzzword buzzword will get huge returns buzzword in the next earnings quarter.
Uh, where's the talk about equity? What are your sales?
What's the real business.
This is going to reward you with a lot of money in the future.
[Inaudible].
Instead of all these reward points cards with clutter and restriction
with one card,
Linus guarantees you cash back into your bank account.
After your routine purchases, how much, what percentage? Uh,
it can vary. It can go from 20 to 40%. Wait a sec.
I go buy something. I get 20% of, yeah, that doesn't happen. That's not real.
The purchase value in cash. Yes, sir. That ain't going to happen.
You got to explain that further. Cause that's absolutely keep going. So the way.
Thank you, sir. You should be sweating.
Dude. Do you guys see, do you guys see this?
Do you guys see the sweat on this man's brow here?
This is why the name shark tank is actually a lot better than Dragon's den
because dragons, you know, sharks smell blood in the water they pounce.
And they're about to rip this guy to shreds. Poor, man.
I feel bad for him cause I don't, I don't even think he's at the top of this.
The way it works is that, uh, the shoppers sign up and register for free.
And Excuse me,
I'm just so nervous. I know this is going to end badly for you.
I want you to know that.
Can we make that a meme in our community?
As soon as we get catch them red flags, it's like,
I know this is going to end badly for you. I want you to know that.
I know this is going to end badly for you.
I want you to know that I want you to let this core man get his pituitary badly.
Probably not. I got to know how I get 20% off my retail purchase.
We let him talk.
I, you know what?
I see these things a lot where like the hosts are not sweating at all.
And then the other guy is the whole time is like sweating
profusely. I think it's a trick of the lights.
I think they put the hot lights on the guy and then they have like cool fans on
the hosts.
Cause nobody normally sweats this much as you'll see in the next clip too.
This isn't just this guy.
All the people pitching they're like sweating profusely.
And I don't think it's just nerves,
Which by the way is genius on the producer's part. If that's true.
The shoppers register for free and a lioness partners
up with retailers to take a
sales commission of the sales, they generate that particular.
I don't even think this guy knows what his own company does.
I don't think he's the owner of it. He doesn't sound like it. Like he doesn't,
he isn't confident in what his own company does. This is what all the MLM is.
Do you ask them what their company does? They're like, well,
we have a distribution chain of logistics.
If you get to the right tier and you get that, the override,
it's going to go ahead and get you rich. They don't understand that.
A retailer, depending on their profit margin,
just like a commission-based salesman in a company.
I get it. I don't get it. I get it. I don't get it. I'm going to,
I'm going to try to explain to you in a simple term,
if I can help you sign us up and then the deal is we should go sign up other
people, right? Absolutely sign up other people's medical pyramid scheme.
We're eight years old, uh, in Europe.
Dead stop. Don't hurt yourself. Bye.
And a pyramid scheme falls up part at the bottom, correct?
Cause every time you move to the top,
the supporters from this is the shoppers, which register for free.
And they're motivated to go use their cards at all their mailers.
I don't make any money. If someone signs up underneath me. Yes you do.
I do absolutely. Oh, pyramid scheme. It's not a pyramid,
large foot circling above your head.
This whole thing is just aroused. I mean, this should, honestly,
this is legal right here. This is manslaughter right now.
This poor man is getting obliterated.
I think our business partner,
the one that I bought is $10,000 and nuts to start
in Canada alone. Andy, how much.
Thousand dollars. That's ridiculous.
I've I've seen Emma limbs for like 500 bucks, 10 grand. This poor man.
He hasn't made his money back. He he's this guy, guy's a lowly peon.
I guarantee it. He acts like it.
Your money. Have you gotten now? Uh, so far I'm on my way, zero,
because I've been very busy. How many years ago did you give him the 10,000.
Sweating meme profusely? I feel bad for this guy at this point.
Now at this point,
knowing what I know he's getting scammed and he's being humiliated all at the
same time. So it is funny cause he's trying to scam other people,
but he also is being scammed. Himself said,
you find out in some of these things, it's like you're getting scammed,
but you're also scamming other people. It's terrible.
Uh, basically it was in, in steps.
The last payment I made was about three months ago or I board, uh,
money against my house. No.
No. Why would you do that? Don't ever borrow money against your house.
This isn't even a scam thing. This poor man has been hoodwinked and bamboozled.
He went into the most aggressive entrepreneurs show to try to pitch the very
idea that he got scammed into and to scam those people. And this is the face
I gotta perfect that face.
I gotta get on these one of these shark tanks sometime soon.
Cause I guarantee you actually no cap. As the kids say,
I'd be a great shark. I just sniff out all these con artists,
liars, et cetera. I wouldn't let any of them through.
And this is the face I'd be giving all of them just like that.
Hey, because the returns overpower any percentage of the returns coming.
The returns are when you give him 35,000, wait a second.
Why would an investor give $10,000 to somebody and never get a return?
He's down. Stopped kicking this man while he's down.
You're going to get a return. You're doing teed your returns.
As soon as you find your Ford direct.
Oh boom. Ah, so.
Oh, we're starting off fakery Friday, right?
Boys hairless sweaty man is not the guru. It's the structure,
the multilevel marketing structure, but I'm going to do it anyway. It's my show.
So I guess this is Fager Friday. Lioness is the name of the scam, by the way,
for those of you who are wondering,
I don't know if I told you guys that in the beginning,
I thought we were just going to find out together, but yeah.
Little give back scam.
Did you buy this from my ex-wife in Europe? Honestly.
How much has she made? It's hard to say because it's in Hungarian, foreigns.
This poor man's life is falling apart. And Kevin Heller is like.
Honestly,
I think the odds of you getting money from the dragons is pretty low. Got it.
Why is that? It's a, it's a straightforward business. I mean, Andy Weir.
Here's the way it works. Just simply they're losing us line us up here.
Okay. Here's me.
And here's the five dragons under me and there's a big foot above you about the
squash because it's a really stupid idea.
Hold on. Can you finish that analogy for me? So that it's you? Yes, here's,
Lina's here's me. And here comes the five dragons underneath me. Got it.
And they start.
And they each pay me $37,000 for the privilege of
joining a pyramid scheme. Yeah. That's going to work.
Their network bigger because everybody that you bring in,
they're going to bring in somebody here. Yes.
And then it gets bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger.
What did I just make handy?
Can we get this nasty P word? The pyramid scheme.
So we started here. Oops, aha. And he's like,
yeah, yeah. What did I make Andy? Oh, this poor man.
You got to feel bad for him. You do.
This is illegal. My friend. This is not something that I would ever invest in.
And neither should you have you have I'm out.
Yep. I don't know if it's a pyramid or not. It is. But my reaction is.
Um, in my opinion, I'm looking at you lying as lawyers in my opinion.
Okay. Maybe it is. Maybe it isn't.
That's why he said that actually is literally. So he doesn't get sued.
Not comfortable selling this to any of my friends while business
associates. So I'm out Eddie.
I don't think you should take any more money and invested in this.
It might not be a good idea. I'm out.
Absolutely. No way. Would I put money into this?
This stuff is distasteful.
Oh, that's a good one. Distasteful. So all right, finish this up.
It doesn't impress me. I'm not impressed by the way.
It's operating as well. So for that reason I'm out.
Thank you. They'll take that with you.
You guys all see y'all all say when I'm worth a hundred million
dollars and I've sold gift cards and credit card give backs to everybody in the
entire world yells, see what you wear now,
if you're like me and you just saw that guy get eviscerated on national
television, I'd stay away. If you're one of these pyramid scheme guys,
but not now the thing with pyramid scheme people, and this is the truth.
This is honest. They believe in themselves like deep down to the core.
They've been indoctrinated that this pyramid scheme is going to change the
world. So they often, they don't see like what everyone else sees.
And you're about to see that.
Oh.
This is already off to a bad start.
When you look like you're about to try to revive Frankenstein with your little
science experiment from the third grade, this is not going to go well.
There's nothing sexy about what I'm seeing right now.
Hello dragons. My name is Paul Lobo. This is Barry Richie.
Okay. Our company is air Oasis limited.
The purpose of us being here is we want 125,000 pounds of your money
and return. We will give you 10% equity in our company.
Our product produces water out of air,
and Barry's not going to give you a brief.
So it's a dehumidifier.
Like if thing that we existed already,
ambitious plans for market penetration,
buried Richie and Paul Luba pitch for 125,000 pounds of investment in
their company. Aero Oasis. Certainly hasn't lacked confidence,
but what's behind it. Confident claims see per fetus wants to know.
Well unfair. I lost about seven P a liter. Yes.
Sounds cheap when you compare it with bottled water. Yes,
but it's not cheap when you compare it to just filter because there's
like that. Just fill tags. If that's without question, without question,
the difference is these don't need a water supply.
So they will be very good in humid countries without question where,
where you can't get water to a unit. Most definitely.
So the UK market,
it's not actually going to be a very good market for this as it.
What I think is actually there's a lot of people that are interested in reducing
their car.
No, no, no, no. [inaudible] I can already tell who the salesman is.
The guy talking right now, not this guy, that guy talking,
he's the salesman who everything always fits his product.
Like you come out of the store and he's like, Oh, do you need a mattress?
And you're like, Oh no, I already have a bed. And he goes, no, no,
no mattresses are great for people that already have beds. And you're like, no,
no. I just bought a mattress yesterday. He's like, actually,
this mattress is great for people who just bought a mattress yesterday.
You're like, no, this doesn't fit what I need right now.
And what is it costing you to buy these they're coming into me. Oh.
Oh, the sweat begins again.
I'm telling you they have heaters on these people so that they sweat during the
presentation. I know it because this is not a normal amount of human, sweat,
salary and pool, a confidence of healthy margins.
But Duncan Bannatyne thinks he's spotted a floor in that plant.
No, it's terrible. I don't like it, but it's shorter.
It says something you said in your pitch.
What you're going to do is educate the public.
You haven't explained how are you going to educate the public?
And you're not going to educate the public.
The public are going to continue using tap water or drinking, bottled water.
Yep. Duncan. Um, soon as you do this test, which is very visual,
really? That's the education. You can't travel around the country,
knocking on people's doors.
Look at how arrogant this hand raises.
I've never seen something worse than this.
I would never invest in somebody who has this face on this is the smuggest face
I've ever seen. And I know it's London or the UK, but this is pretty bad.
Even for you guys.
And people's doors going in with two glasses of water and sending people look at
the difference by one of these machines, you can't do that.
That's we can can't educate the public.
We've just got a hundred kits in little cases.
This is like the Kirby vacuum cleaner. This is the bugs under them on the bed.
Under the microscope,
we've got 300 people sign up to go out door to door on commission. Only
mother buddy. The point I'm making isn't that you can't grow knocking on doors.
The point I'm making is you can't afford to go around knocking on doors.
Hold off. No, actually let me make this more accurate. Kinda get a little,
a little water here. Hold on. It's going to be too much. All right. No,
it's good.
Oh really? Really? I can't do it really. Huh?
There's not enough. Money it to go knocking on doors and saying to people, look,
where are you like me? Come in.
It should use two glasses of water and show the difference. It ain't.
You can buy my machine for 500 quid.
But there is because that doesn't cost them. And we bought all the kits.
The people are taken on a part-time only basis.
They get a hundred pounds a sale. They do three in a week. They get 150%.
It's good. Old fashioned pyramid. Multi-level direct Mark.
Uh, oops. You know, you see God himself. It's good.
Old fashioned pyramid scheme, multi, uh,
multi-level uh.
Being awake. They get it's good. Old fashioned pyramid.
Multi-level direct markets.
Did you see, Oh gosh,
I have to explain something for you guys to fully get the context of this
pyramid. It used to be called pyramid selling. Then they rebranded it.
After everyone realized that was the scam to multi-level marketing.
Everyone realized that was a scam. So they renamed it to direct selling.
This guy has been in the game so long that he goes through fluidly,
all three words for it seamlessly. Oh, this is incredible.
Price. I was the top salesman.
You run the risk of talking yourself back down those days without an investment.
Okay.
The reason I asked if you'd been a Kirby selling person is that I could have
told you where, because actually what you used to do is done in people's room,
bombard them and barrage them exactly the way you're trying to do with us now,
until they capitulate and buy that carpet cleaner.
I've seen the selling techniques, which I have to say really, really annoys me.
Uh, you are talking about.
This. Guy's confidence is slowly diminishing.
If you see the face is getting sweaty or both of ours are,
and uh, the confidence is going away.
The smugness going away didn't have all the answers.
But a pyramid selling scheme. I've got to tell you for me,
that is a combination that I would run a mile from. Okay?
So I have no reason to invest. I might click.
The atmosphere in the Dennis darkening,
a furious Deborah Meaden wants nothing to do with the duo.
And she's not the only dragon to be alienated by the pitch.
As a business proposition.
Does this excite me for 150,000 pounds?
No working with Barry would just drive me crazy.
I don't think I could handle it. And for those reasons, guys, I'm out.
There's guys getting eviscerated and nobody's coming to save them.
That's my favorite part.
Dragons around pool. How do you work with this guy? Um, very well. Um,
I love his enthusiasm. No, no, no. I, I get Barry.
I don't get you leave everything. Barry says no, not at all.
Two men and a business. Always agree. One of them is unnecessary.
I only see one unnecessary man here.
How much money have you made? Have you got money to put into it? Yes, I have.
I put, I put in 150,000 pounds. So you put it in 150,000 of your own cash.
Yes. And Barry, I'm about 50 at about a million and a hard work.
This man is so sassy. Can I just say Adam out of value and of hard work,
relax, dude. Yes.
You got to have the right partner in a partnership and Barry's not cutting it.
I got to say, have you got any more money?
Well, of course I've got more money. How much more money have you got? Well,
I don't think that concerns you. It does concern me.
How much money have you got?
You're asking for an investment.
Of course it concerns him how much his investors have to put in the business
that may be failing very soon. This is.
Probably about 10 million in the bank.
That's so I don't think that's a valid question. Well, I'll tell you why.
It's a valid question. If you've got the money,
why aren't you putting the blood? Let me, let us explain why we want your,
your expertise, your knowledge, so that we can really go.
But why should I give you money for you to get managed for me? Well,
we're not a charity. We're not going to let you have a.
They're not a charity. They can look at this guy.
My face when gurus tried to pitch me a pyramid scheme on Dragon's den.
Well knowledge for me and my money. Absolutely. Exactly.
I haven't got mugged written over my forehead. You know?
Um, I don't know British, but I'm assuming that that's a bacon, salt mug.
I don't know my UK. Editor's going to have to explain that one. To me.
Aged Peter Jones has blasted the geo.
The dragons are clearly infuriated by the entrepreneurs themselves.
[Inaudible].
Barry and Paul's only hope now is to salvage their pitch by proving their water
tastes as good as they say.
This is good. This is good. Reset the pitch. Yes, you're a pyramid scheme,
but maybe your pyramid scheme tastes great.
Buddy. It tastes terrible.
Terrible all this conversations, but not this sort of test in the war.
Is that water that's cause it's warm. That's why unusual tastes. Oh.
No unusual taste.
That's a bad adjective for water. Unusual.
That'd be [inaudible]. There's something in it. There's nothing in it.
Or use your glass.
I drink all that water mayhem erupts in the den.
You thought they were sweating before. It's just getting started.
It's got an aftertaste.
The Dragon's declared Berry and water to be totally unpalatable revolting.
My kids will throw that back at you. Theo per fetus.
Guys. I swear I can.
Taste it.
Terrible or not. It doesn't say it's terrible,
but it certainly doesn't taste as good as it should do.
But it's a brand spanking new machine that needed to be flushed and everything
else properly. This is.
It's a, brand's making new machine that doesn't work.
I don't know what's going on here, guys.
It needs to be set for a longer.
Period of time in order to five hours to get it working properly.
Was a temporary. Hey, I'll tell you how long it takes to get your tap water.
She's four to five hours.
Uh, 21 degrees. Just listen to me. They'll get really annoyed.
Now I'm complaining.
About the temperature,
but the fat has got a terrible appalling after taste.
So don't make excuses about the temperature. I'm out.
It's all bits over for Barry and Paul. They,
it by Theo per fetus now Duncan Bannatyne and Peter Jones.
Step forward to have their say.
The thing is w w what gets me is this,
you did all these tests and his war to shoot your war is the best. Yes, yes.
Then I tested your water. Yes, yes. And it's rubbish. Yes. We all tested it.
Most of the same thing. Yes.
And then you said that's because that machine hasn't been flushed. Yes.
In order for you to see our machine in its full
operation, it would have been fair for this machine to be here overnight.
Then it would have been where you've gone from.
They would have gone from justice. You've gone from an hour and a half, Joel,
Nate now, but it doesn't answer my question. Um, and you know,
I'm not gonna invest in it. So I'm, uh, Paul Barry,
you've basically bought a product here that lives or dies on the back of the
quality that it produces. Can I say in all the times that we,
he doesn't even make a point, he just goes of the quality that it produces.
Saying all the times.
That we've tasted that water amongst you dragons.
That's the first time it's unfortunate being like this.
That's all I can say to you.
I think enough has been said by everybody else.
And I don't think he hit necessarily to be insulted,
so good luck in your endeavors,
but I'm not going to invest in the business I'm out.
Okay. Okay. Fair enough. Barry.
And Paul have felt the full force of.
All right. And that's it guys. That's how you invest in,
or that's how you pitch a pyramid scheme on Dragon's den. Whew,
rough. Even for me, get a little, get a fan in here. Uh,
actually hold on. Think we can
$10 million studio guys. We got fan technology. Uh, anyways,
I hope you enjoy this lighthearted episode of fake guru Friday.
In this case, the fake guru is pyramid schemes.
And I guess the people getting scammed are the people investing in those pyramid
schemes and taking them on these reality shows to be trashed in front of the
entire world. I hope you learned your lesson guys. Don't do it again.
Thank you for watching. Gosh, it feels good to be daily. Huh? It used to be,
I took the weekend off, but now, Hey, see you tomorrow.